à écrire sur une mosquée devait venir du Coran.
J'ai donc choisi ce verset :
« Oh humanité, nous t'avons créée à partir d'un homme et d'une femme,
et t'avons faite de gens et de tribus, pour que vous vous connaissiez. »
C'était un appel universel de paix, tolérance et acceptation,
provenant d'un acteur que les médias
ne décrivent pas toujours de manière positive.
j'ai été émerveillé par la réaction de la communauté locale à cette peinture,
et leur fierté de voir le minaret être au centre d'autant d'attention
de la part de la presse internationale.
Pour l'Imam, ce n'était pas juste une peinture ;
c'était plus profond.
Il espérait que le minaret devienne un monument pour la ville,
et qu'il attire du monde vers ce coin oublié de Tunisie.
L'universalité du message,
le contexte politique de la Tunisie à ce moment,
et le fait que j'écrive du Coran sous forme de graffiti
avaient un sens.
Ça a réuni la communauté.
Rapprocher les gens et les générations futures,
à travers la calligraphie arabisante :
voilà ma spécialité.
Écrire des messages est l'essence de mon travail d'artiste.
C'est amusant car même ceux dont l'arabe est la langue maternelle
doivent vraiment se concentrer pour déchiffrer ce que j'écris.
Pas besoin de comprendre le sens pour apprécier l’œuvre.
Je pense que l'écriture arabe touche votre âme avant d'atteindre vos yeux.
Elle a une beauté qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de traduire.
L'écriture arabe parle à tout le monde, je pense.
A vous, à vous, à vous aussi, à n'importe qui.
Quand vous en comprenez le sens,
vous vous y sentez connecté.
Je fais toujours attention d'écrire
des messages qui sont en accord avec le lieu où je peins,
des messages qui ont une dimension internationale,
pour que tout le monde puisse s'y connecter.
Je suis né et j'ai grandi en France, à Paris,
et j'ai commencé a apprendre à lire et écrire l'arabe à 18 ans.
Aujourd'hui j'écris seulement des messages en arabe.
Une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est important pour moi,
émane de toutes les réactions que j'ai reçues dans le monde entier.
A Rio de Janeiro, j'ai traduit ce poème portugais
de Gabriela Tôrres Barbosa,
qui rendait hommage aux indigents des favelas.
Je l'ai peint sur un toit.
Les habitants étaient vraiment intrigués par mon travail,
mais dès que je leur expliqué le sens de la calligraphie,
ils m'ont remercié, car ils se sentaient liés à cette peinture.
En Afrique du Sud, à Cape Town,
la communauté des Philippi
m'a offert le seul mur en béton de ce quartier pauvre.
C'était une école.
J'y ai écrit une citation de Nelson Mandela,
qui dit [En arabe] :
« Ça paraît impossible tant que ce n'est pas fait. »
Puis ce type est venu me dire : « Mec, pourquoi t'écris pas en anglais ? »
Je lui ai répondu : « Ta demande serait légitime
si tu me demandais pourquoi je n'écris pas en zulu. »
A Paris, il y a eu cet événement,
où quelqu'un a donné son mur à peindre.
Et quand il a vu que je peignais en arabe,
ça l'a énervé, il était hystérique, et il a demandé que le mur soit effacé.
J'étais furieux et déçu.
Mais une semaine plus tard, l'organisateur m'a demandé de revenir.
Il m'a dit qu'il y avait un mur juste en face de la maison de ce type.
Donc, ce type,
(Rires)
était forcé de le voir tous les jours.
Ma première idée était d'écrire : [En arabe]
ce qui signifie, « dans les dents. »
(Rires)
Mais j'ai décidé d’être plus intelligent et j'ai écrit [En Arabe]
« Ouvre ton cœur. »
Je suis très fier de ma culture,
et j'essaye d'en être l’ambassadeur à travers mon travail.
J’espère pouvoir briser les stéréotypes que nous connaissons tous,
avec la beauté de l'écriture arabe.
Aujourd'hui, je n'écris plus la traduction des messages sur les murs.
Je ne veux pas que la poésie de la calligraphie soit brisée.
C'est de l'art et vous pouvez l'apprécier sans en connaître le sens,
comme vous pouvez apprécier n'importe quelle musique étrangère.
Certaines personnes voient ça comme un rejet ou une porte close.
Pour moi c'est plus une invitation,
à découvrir mon langage, ma culture et mon art.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)